my husband spends over $1,000 a month
just on phone games on his iPhone when
you say that out loud does it sound as
crazy to you as it does to me yes like
this is this is this is like illness
level what's your household income
83,000 $83,000 how old is your husband
29 okay I'm a stay-at-home mom yeah am
the one that pays the bills yeah I pinch
money wherever I can okay so that we can
get those paid you're you you guys need
to see you need to get some professional
help that's what I'm thinking too yeah
because this is not a
$100 uh and he makes 200,000 they've
carefully designed the games to create a
dopamine hit to cause you to come back
again and again and again they designed
these games to be addictive